and the people who are in charge of the
world all they've ever wanted from the
beginning is control these people are
above money they're above economies
they're above the dollar they're above
the lay they're above this [ __ ] they
want people to comply when you're at
that level all you care about is that
the idiots at the bottom comply this is
what you need and you have to put
systems in place to ensure people comply
and one of the easiest systems you can
do is by manipulating information if I
type covid into Google nothing will come
up saying it's a scam everything will
come up saying it's so dangerous stay
home locked down blah blah blah Google
have decided to propagate the covid LIE
they have not decided to be fair and
impartial and show people the things
that make them think opposite they want
people to be afraid I I want to tell you
why I think this isn't that insane like
with school you're initially taught to
do research on both sides and since
covert that's basically just been
destroyed you're just supposed to trust
the media and everything that they tell
you it's wild and now if you say
anything even questioning this the value
there the the back Bean or anything like
that it's just misinformation because
that's when Biden came out and he made
the speech about anything against the
vaccine is misinformation look in the
mirror
think about that misinformation
going to your son your daughter and then
we already know that the government can
go behind in the back door of these
social media companies and tell them
what they can and can't to have shared
on their platform they did it with the
hunter Biden video before the election
they've done it with covid you can't say
anything against it or your whole
platform gets removed it's so obvious of
the agenda that they're trying to push
especially since from from since the
beginning they were showing videos of
people just dropping dead in the streets
and constantly shoving it down your
throat that you need to be afraid of
this yeah it's insane yeah what you said
what you said
I think I think not because Google or
YouTube are part of the global
conspiracy no but they do believe
I understand that's why they are doing
it cool that's my opinion okay they're
wrong oh great so but if Google and
YouTube Believe X yeah and they
manipulate the population of the world
in x-way and these are the most powerful
institutions on Earth and right now that
we say Okay covet it's fine but Andrea
let me tell you it's really not as crazy
as you think when these people have
unlimited resources like if they can
control the media and social media to
control what you think is it really that
crazy that all this happened people
think like there's no way a global
Elites could do this bro I feel like if
I was in a room with a couple other me's
not trying to toot my own horn but I
feel like I could figure some [ __ ] out
to control people you know what I mean
yeah you do it I'm an amazing marketer
okay I'll give it to myself I know how
to influence people to get what I want
you know what I mean I have 80 million
views in the last two months and you
could use your power from I have over
100 million views on Tick Tock in the
last couple months from people reposting
my content that's me deliberately saying
things making announcements that I know
will get stuff to benefit me and it'll
also benefit them because you know
they're just getting starts in their
affiliate accounts it's stuff like that
that's one of the things I teach too is
how to influence people so I'll give a
quick story when I first started this
Social Media stuff to further help me
blowing up on Tick Tock I went on an ALT
account like a different account than my
main and I tagged over a hundred hate
Tick Tock accounts and I said check out
Sunny Fez on YouTube he reacts to Tate
with his mom that's all I said and I
tagged basically every single Tate
account I could find and a week later I
had 10 million views you know what I
mean like there's so many ways where you
can manipulate people where manipulate
where they don't even realize that that
was your intention so it isn't as crazy
to me that there's Elites that run the
world right I hate that you use the word
manipulate you know what I mean I know
yeah I manipulate like but that's what
that's influence influence or or you
know make them aware of things right so
you can control a narrative so you
tagged up in your example you know you
tagged all these things they became
aware of it they liked it they decided
to share it it worked uh what they're
doing here though is is just Sinister
and that's what's really disturbing
about it everything everyone everyone
says has an agenda that that goes along
with it okay like me making this YouTube
video I I obviously love making YouTube
videos but it's also so that I can make
a full income stream off of making
content you know I have my motives for
doing this and because you have motives
and an agenda it doesn't always mean
it's malintentioned or bad you know I'm
pretty open about mine again the people
understand what I'm up to but these
people are just [ __ ] all right let's
keep going I always strive for the truth
of course they don't manipulate okay
they have the right because if you have
on a platform if you Google yours yours
you are free to make your own rules
now this is an interesting art terrible
argument but firstly I disagree with you
they do manipulate because if they
control the information people see they
manipulate what's the difference between
manipulating and influencing there's no
difference okay yeah they influence they
manipulate whatever you want to say it
yeah but even now you're manipulating
people okay of course but if you're a
search engine right yeah you're a search
engine you're supposed to provide
results impartially you're supposed to
say here's information if you have an
agenda which which the which these
companies do including YouTube If you
have an agenda that's fine but you are
influencing you are manipulating and
that becomes dangerous Beyond covid when
you start looking at things like
presidential elections and how they're
manipulating people to hate president
Trump yeah how they're manipulating
people to hate certain political
components this is a dangerous thing but
you have people out there who are in
charge of these institutions like you
said and it's their Fair decision to do
what they want but they can control
billions of people's minds yes so if
they sit there and go
this politician will do whatever we want
and this one won't he's bad he's good
these people control the world if you
that's not fair there should be fair
access to information no there should be
freedom and they should be let free to
do whatever they want okay but they have
an absolute Monopoly they have an
absolute Monopoly yes the greatest
Monopoly ever let us build our own
platform this is how I see it I may I
may not
I don't have the truth okay but this is
how I think I think they should be
everybody should be left to do whatever
they want man you have Google is Google
yours you can make your own rules man
yeah there was a time when I agree
with with uh
Andy there was a time that I agreed with
him in that I believe that they were a
commercial Enterprise and they should be
able to make their own rules but as I've
said before they are now so deeply
ingrained in our Global society as a as
a major is the only way to the the
primary way to get information out you
know basic information like oh [ __ ] the
lights are out in your area there was an
earthquake uh there was a you know
there's a 10 car pile up on the highway
don't go there to you know stay away
from the area this is it's it's Akin
again to a utility it is something that
everybody or at least every uh agency in
business runs on and operates with akin
to electricity and gas so uh and basic
infrastructure in in the world here in
the U.S and which is you know my my
world so it is no longer just a free
company it's not like I I go to this
office and I work there and they can
hang anything they want on the Walls
Within that thing they have a larger
responsibility now and it has to change
in the in mind and the thing is too with
like the tape band he followed all their
Community guidelines so if you have
rules and stuff and if people don't
break them then what justifies you just
going off and banning them that's not
fair if a business can't just deny you
coming in and buying something from
their store because of your race or
political view so what's the difference
from Banning these entertain on social
media when he didn't break any rules any
laws any laws or any rules well and what
the con
their rules are whatever we [ __ ] say
goes so they can write a thousand pages
about rules but at the end of it it's
whatever they want okay so forget the
nitty-gritty of their rules because the
big over whatever the [ __ ] Susan says is
the rule overrides all the other rules
your best point that you've made is how
you said that you know the reason we
have the Constitution is to keep our
amendments and or something like that or
the government is to keep our
constitutional rights and so if the
these social media companies which
basically control how people think they
don't allow Free Speech then how is the
government doing their job you know what
I mean when there's something that is so
pervasive in our society and so critical
to our society is basic functioning at
this point like water I agree with you
yeah absolutely then people need to
understand that the information that
gets manipulated I understand that yeah
but most but most people don't so let's
hope YouTube leaves this video up and
doesn't strike it so I'm telling you
guys so not good so YouTube if you're
watching any video on YouTube understand
that YouTubers deliberately manipulating
the search results what you type into
the search bar is deliberately
manipulated to try and convince you of a
certain thing when you type covet into
the search results it's going to tell
you how scared to be it's never going to
tell you it's a scam this is done on
purpose if you want information you have
to find it in other places and it does
exist it does exist on Fringe websites
which are very hard to find and very
hard to keep up because they all
disappear there's a website called bit
shoot which is the YouTube of Freedom
right you can say anything racist things
anti-covered things it's completely free
unlike YouTube on Election Day it
disappeared it got shut down Google this
and [ __ ] you themselves couldn't work
out why they got hacked by somebody who
was trying to stop them putting up proof
that the presidential election was
rigged and somebody probably Google or
YouTube themselves hot all right we can
cut it off here because that's that's a
whole conversation that I I'm not ready
to have what I really want to have oh no
he goes deep into it I really want it so
uh cousin Rob the other day uh called
and he told me I I gotta pull it back up
again I don't remember the name book
that is like basically outlines Point by
Point by point you know that the
election was stolen um I want to read
that book I want to read another book
that agrees with it and I want to read a
couple books that say no it was not
stolen and I really do want to get into
that conversation because I think that
it's not over the conversation is not
over and I think in 5 10 20 maybe maybe
I'll die before if before the the real
facts come out but there's more to that
story and anyone that's denying it is is
just naive and it could have been and it
could have I believe that there's
election interference at every level
from from yeah and the right also had
high school you know high school I'm
sure the president elections right up to
the White House I think there there was
proof of the right also doing some some
bad stuff yeah that's what I'm saying
there's [ __ ] all over they all have [ __ ]
and blood on their hands all of them
again United We Stand can't say it
enough this was fun tonight thanks guys
for being here make sure you join the
Discord uh my full Academy drops very
soon and you don't want to miss out on
it um that is not an exaggeration the
first thousand people get in for 29.99 a
month for every price I have goals to
get this price over to 100 a month
because once people see the value the
demand will be there you know my social
media knowledge is not we're gonna have
a lot of fun with that when I was first
telling people I wanted to make like a
course and stuff they they told me like
it's too valuable to even put out there
like you shouldn't even do it [ __ ] that
let's put it out there let's let listen
I'm just saying this is this is a place
where everybody can either create their
own content and get out there and earn a
living making your own living allows
Freedom if you if you have something
that you can bring to the table or if
somebody else has something they can
bring to the table they can pay you to
use this knowledge there's if you're
into if you're into it and I think I
think you should be because I'm having a
ball I don't know about you don't we
have so much fun together oh yeah all
the time except when he farts on me
[Music]
won't last long yeah
[Music]